what's been your favorite look I think
one of my favorite looks was the one
before this one we just I'm sure you
know I don't know but um which was a
little bit of a darker smokey eye so I
feel like it would be more manageable
for like the everyday going to dinner
look and then it was a really gorgeous
lip color which was the it's the new
nourishing lip by Bobby Brown it's
called desert rose would you say you
played good at doing makeup I would say
I'm pretty good but I still am learning
new tricks every day like I'm I'm
excited about this eye shadow that I'm
wearing which is a black it's called
black plum I think it's fun because it
adds something different to a smoky eye
than just brown and black what's the
best beauty trick you've learned I kept
having trouble with gel liner because I
don't have a steady hand and I learned
that if you dip the brush at both sides
in the gel liner it creates a better
point that you can just draw the line
perfectly after that because you always
seem like you always have giggles upbeat
and always kind of confident how do you
stay
what are the things that you know you do
have that kind of confidence I guess I
take my job seriously but I don't take
myself very serious so I'm able to laugh
right like you know everybody has bad
days but I'm able to laugh about it and
see the humor in it and I think that
that helps especially when you're tired
and I also I really try to take care of
myself I try to work out and drink lots
of water and get facials and you know I
try to treat myself every now and again
to keep me from feeling rundown what's
the funniest to treat me you've ever had
actually this was just recently I went
to Bliss Spa and it's a great treatment
I really recommend it and they they
waxed my nose hairs and they like take
hard wax and they put it inside your
nostril and they leave the steak facing
up and then they just they ran out and
all and I know it that's exactly what I
thought I was like freaking out I was so
nervous about it and and it really it
didn't hurt that badly a hundred percent
the web of my life is my dog Harley uber
I went to go places I got phrases to go
people to see
or maybe just my dog to see what music
are you I'm Adele I love her she's she's
really amazing she gives me chills I
think there was one night that I
literally watched Adele videos until
like 2:00 in the morning well can I just
say thank you for being the most awesome
person
to ever be on a shoot with honestly
we've had like thank you